Ukrainian troops installing a new border
post on the Strategic snake island in
the Black Sea it was famously
temporarily captured by Russia last year
with this footage released amid a new
escalation in the conflict elsewhere in
the Black Sea the Russian Navy says it
fired warning shots beside a neutral
cargo ship near Turkish waters before
briefly boarding it to inspect its
contents Moscow says the circle okan was
on its way to the small Ukrainian Port
of Ismail shipping data says it was
bound for a Romanian port
since Russia ended the Black Sea Green
initiative last month Moscow has ordered
strikes on the primary port city of
Odessa drone attacks hit Ismail 2 after
other Merchant ships prepared to pick up
grain there certainly the Russians have
feared that this is what the Ukraine
players going to be to bust the blockade
analyst Professor Scott Lucas says it's
accepted that warring Nations can
inspect neutral vessels however there's
an easy political and legal answer here
which is Russia's never declared war on
Ukraine for Ukraine exporting by ship is
much cheaper than complex land routes so
ships being prepared to run the Black
Sea Gauntlet could be key to the
viability of its grain exports Redmond
Shannon Global News London